vw oder bmw oder mercedes heute über
eine rüstungsmesse und den neuen
kampfpanzer von rheinmetall
er schießt weiter als alle
vergleichbaren panzer er schießt härter
als alle vergleichbaren panzer er lässt
größere ladungen fliegen er heißt
panther und hat alles was er braucht um
auf den schlachtfeldern der zukunft zu
bestehen
[Musik]
der panzer ist eine deutlich größere
kanone als bisherige panzer neuer bauart
ist ein das zweite der zweite wichtige
aspekt ist es ein exportmodell viele
panzer sollen in den kommenden jahren
erneuert werden gerade im westen und
dafür ist dieser panzer vorgesehen
die vielleicht wichtigste neuerung die
neue 130 mm kanone l 51 wird automatisch
geladen und damit kann der panther auch
die front panzerung von russischen
panzern neuester bauart wie dem t14 oder
t90 durchschlagen die antwort auf putins
super panzer marta ist damit da
als et 14 der amata den panzer neuester
bauart großen vorgestellt wurde war es
für viele westliche beobachter ein
schock und man stellte sich die frage
brauchen wir jetzt ein panzer mit
größeren kaliber einen mobileren panzer
der schneller ist der cdu bad und das
ist dass es die parallele ob man den
namen jetzt so glücklich gewählt hat das
muss rheinmetall noch selber beantworten
denn der panther war auch im zweiten
weltkrieg der am meisten eingesetzte
deutsche panzer über 6000 wurden
produziert ebenfalls bekannt der panther
ist eine deutsche eigenentwicklung von
rheinmetall und steht damit in
konkurrenz zu einem geplanten
deutsch-französischen panzer glaube die
franzosen wären nicht ganz so erfreut
sein auch deutschland ist vielleicht
nicht ganz so erfreut weil
der panzer wird 2030 wahrscheinlich
schon im einsatz stehen das
deutsch-französische projekt wird
wahrscheinlich vor 2040 abgeschlossen
seien
jedoch für den ukraine krieg kommt der
panther vermutlich zu spät aber wenn es
nach den plänen des kreml herrschers
putin geht bleibt er sogar bis 2036 im
amt bis dahin könnte der panther längst
im einsatz sein